foreign
let's go to Christy in San Antonio
what's up Christy
hello how we doing good morning I'm good
sorry I had a little bit of a cold oh no
it's all good
um how are you
I'm good really good just enjoying the
weather finally cooling down here in San
Antonio very cool I was in Houston
yesterday and it was much warmer that is
here in Nashville hopefully you guys
will get some more cool weather coming
I hope so you know 80s is better than
100 so I I can hang with that for a few
months 80s that's like the depth of
winter for San Antonio
yeah it is so how can I help what's up
all right so I I'm so grateful you were
willing to take our call
um I love your show and uh so I have a
wonderful amazing husband and we have
three beautiful kids
and uh we met in the Mormon church we
married in the Mormon Church we're very
Mormon
we are very if I had a t-shirt company I
would make a shirt that just said we are
very Mormon
yeah because because hey here's what's
funny I'm not Mormon and I know exactly
what you mean this is so great so good
yeah when people see me you know when I
make friends with people like yeah you
had a Mormon five yeah you know that's
me I guess very cool fortunately or
unfortunately you get to pick there you
go so you are very y'all y'all the gang
is very Mormon yeah
we just yeah we're in it so all right
you're in about yeah so when covet hit
you know we stopped going to church and
my husband had some legit questions and
so the past couple years he's been
looking into our history and things like
that and recently he's kind of put a
firm
stop to that meaning he's decided that
the Mormon church is not
it's not legitimate and it's not true
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
uh you know just strange awful things
that happened in our history
embarrassing things sure and I am I
totally understand where he's coming
from
I just have a different perspective than
he does
and so I want to keep going but I'm
willing to work with him and compromise
and go to the Mormon church every other
week then go to another church every
other week like I am willing to do that
and teach our kids open-mindedly and
teach them you know to think for
themselves and kind of come to an
understanding on their own of what their
personal belief Sciences beliefs should
are very personal and it should be a
personal Journey
so I'm willing to do that so we keep on
hitting this wall of
you know he just really has a hard time
with us continuing to go
um there's just a lot of things that you
know they when one parent doesn't really
believe sometimes they say well let's
pray for your parent you know little
things like that
um and he just doesn't want to be
painted as a bad figure and to me that's
something that we have control over as
parents
and we get to decide you know what our
how our children view us and we have to
talk about things that they're they're
taught or that they're here
Etc and we get a voice I think he feels
a little differently sure and so you
know he's having a hard time respecting
my desire to want to keep going
um when he's just had such a hard time
with
um you know his side of things does he
have a personal
experience
that has emerged
uh because of it yeah I mean
to be down his whole mission
um I don't think he's ever
I don't think he's ever drank the
Kool-Aid okay does that make sense yeah
totally she's always looked at everyone
be like this is you know this is kind of
weird but maybe I just need to try a
little harder okay kind of thing
I think he's always kind of viewed it
that way I could be wrong what do you
use
you said he's got very valid questions
very valid
uh yeah concerns always
when you say you have a different
perspective I heard it said this way
once um I have a close friend who's a
just an extraordinary theology professor
and very much an atheist
and right we sat by each other in in
church and I asked him once like why do
you still come and he said something
that was profound he said this is my
ethnicity
he said this is my culture this is when
I walk into this building I exhale I
right I feel at home here even though I
don't buy everything that's coming from
the pulpit I still believe in the
positivity and I still believe in
community and I still believe in
stopping every week to remember so he
had had
um really Dove it Dove deep and found uh
a way to get to the to continue the
practices while also having different
thoughts
why do you
feel it's important to continue to go
because here's why where this is
important if ultimately you and your
husband land on different Cosmic beliefs
meaning
there is a truck coming down the highway
and if we don't push our kids out of the
way they're going to get hit by this
truck
yeah if if our kids don't go to this
particular building and are not baptized
in this particular denomination this
particular way and they are going to
spend eternity burning in Hell or
whatever the cosmic punishment is in the
Mormon church
then we have to address that and if the
other person says this is all crazy none
of this is real
now you're going to have a problem if
it's like my buddy if this is simply
this is where I feel comfortable this is
where I feel safe this is all I know and
I'm not interested in blowing up
everything that's a different
conversation because that is we're gonna
practice we're gonna have you see what
I'm saying we can we can be slowly
expand that Circle that's different so
where are you in this conversation
interesting I think some Mormons
probably do think if they their children
don't get baptized then or they don't
get married in the temple then they're
going to you know who knows they're not
they're not gonna make it I don't know
eternally but I do not feel that way and
I've never felt that way okay so so what
is that what does the church get you
true and it's inspired okay so I mean I
just like I love the Book of Mormon I
think it's inspired and I think thoughts
can Inspire men in lots of different
areas but this particular church just
speaks to me and it is my home
absolutely I was raised in it but uh
just the doctrines
um if you take away all the history and
just have the doctrine it makes a lot of
sense
man if you take away all those things
that yeah that that one coach did oh man
there's plays you drew up are great
um okay so there's messed up history and
I don't have the answers to that oh
there's dude there's messed up history
in every organization that's ever
existed right let's be honest every
organization yeah yeah so here's the
here's the listener plot twist Brandon's
on the other line do you know this
Christy
uh yeah I think he said that he wanted
to join so okay so I want to make sure
this isn't like a Jerry Springer like
where we like gotcha okay all right
um
I know yeah uh Jenna can you you bring
them both in
Brandon you there
I'm here John what's up man
just I wish this was a Jerry Springer
situation
he's so great you are not the father
Brandon hey so um Christy has walked us
through and you've probably been
listening
um I'd love to hear your side of what's
going on
yeah I mean a lot of what she said is
pretty valid uh telling the story I
think like
you know sometime during covid there's
definitely little uh tension in our
marriage about how we're teaching our
kids because she would you know want to
teach my children things and I for some
reason started to feel kind of
uncomfortable like it was just something
about my children of like they're gonna
believe anything I tell them and that
really caused a lot of like
self-reflection of just like well why do
I believe what I believe right and so
hey hey hold on good parenting for both
of you like good parenting for
understanding both of y'all seem to
understand that hey these kids are
impressionable we need to be intentional
about what we're passing along to them
good for you that's incredible
oh thanks for trying
all right so I interrupted you go ahead
no you're fine but yeah
um that just kind of caused a real
questioning thing of like well you know
do I really want to tell my kids this if
I don't really
you know know for sure because it's more
of like I'm a good kid I I've did
whatever my parents told me you know I
didn't really ever question anything
before like yeah a lot of stuff was
weird and that's fine you know I grew up
in an area where there weren't a lot of
people in my face so like I kind of knew
that you know we're kind of weird in
some ways and that's fine but like
um yeah it just sort of caused this
trickle effect of really questioning
like well what do I believe why do I do
it and I just didn't want to give my
kids like tell them all these things and
give them all this baggage if it wasn't
right right so that's what caused me to
dig into it and uh it's been I'd say the
biggest aspect it's difficult
um you know through that thing is just
I feel differently now and that wasn't
what I signed up for and wanted
um that wasn't the answer I wanted like
this is a very uh inconvenient annoying
thing that is the taxing on a variety of
levels
um but you know at the core of like what
we're saying we're trying to do what's
best for our kids and I think I think
for me the hardest aspect is I really
want to respect you know like what my
wife's talking about of like Meet 50 50
or respect what she's saying but like I
feel like I'm just disrespecting her in
that process of like well yeah she's
telling you all this but this isn't how
it is because of this and that's that's
where I feel like I'm making her out to
be some kind of villain while at the
same time kind of how I was taught how I
was raised in this church of we have
this is what you think this is your
salvation it's completely contradictory
right like they're going to be told that
you know the exact opposite of what I
think and so that's where I just feel a
lot of times just like stuck of like
well how do we navigate this how can I
respect her and her beliefs because I
want to do so while also
not giving them things that they don't
necessarily need to go down just for uh
difficult reasons if that makes sense
absolutely all right
um since both of you are on the phone
this is this is rare for me I love this
because I can actually have both of you
on here
um
I want to throw two grenades into the
middle of the couch y'all are sitting on
and let me know if I'm off okay
here's grenade number one Brandon I
don't think you've believed for a long
long time true or false
foreign
it was like it was like I was like
forcing myself to so I mean there's
definitely some validity into what
you're saying but like I never
questioned it like I just kept thinking
why I don't feel this way is because I'm
not following things correctly so yeah
you're not good enough yeah yeah
very long time and the reason I didn't
have like a strong confirmation of that
is because I just guess I wasn't trying
enough
okay but no that's a fair grenade but
like it's not yeah it's not exactly like
that to put to an Accenture so when
people lose their faith or when they
deconstruct it or they begin to pull
apart what they've been told their whole
lives or like you mentioned I just never
questioned it I kind of rolled my eyes
that I did what was the I did the next
thing in front of me
um and by the way this happens with
um
some people find themselves two kids
into a marriage at seven years old and
like what am I doing like I just did the
next thing in front of me some people do
find that professionally and they find
themselves an associate vice president
at a company they don't care at all
about in a job but they hate like so
faith is is an integral part of us right
and by the way I I believe the David
Foster Wallace there's no such thing as
an atheist you worship something whether
it's science or a CrossFit or some sort
of deity you you worship we all
everybody worships something your diet
whatever it is
so
it can often feel
um deceptive
like one of y'all like you lied to me or
you're not who I thought I married or if
you really go back and say
um you know I don't think I ever really
bought into this I just did it because I
was a good compliant kid
but I don't ever believe in fill in the
blank it's easy for Christy to then go
well who did I attach my wagon to right
like I signed up for something that you
weren't right so there could be this
this picture of dishonesty so before we
go further I want to make sure both of
y'all are on the same page
it doesn't sound like there's anybody
tricked anybody or bait and switched
anybody or we both on all everybody on
the same page on that one
yeah yeah this is a it's a legitimate
I'm growing right which is a which is a
challenge that all marriages face
um all right so
here's the
here's the second grenade
Brandon
I would be willing to bet and again I
love it when I'm wrong so tell me I'm
wrong
that all this focus on your kids
is an easy place to put marital tension
like we got to do this for the kids we
got to fix this for the kids we got to
get the right answers for the kids we
got to be consistent for the kids lets
us avoid looking across the table at the
woman or man that we love and say
like I'm losing respect for you I can't
imagine how you could believe this
you're not as smart as I thought you
were like really deep seated challenging
questions am I right or am I off
[Music]
um
so more or less like we're putting
Children First in marriage second and
because of that I'm I'm thinking less of
my wife is that the question
no I'm um
spending a lot of energy worrying about
the kids allows you to avoid the person
sitting in front of you
a little bit of that like when you're
talking about like how can you think
that but like I I really think I'd say
the argument's turned into a little bit
of us more than the kids in some ways so
Kristen what do you think or Christy
what do you think
I want to say ding ding ding ding ding
ding
yes okay I think I ah I do I think that
and honestly I think at the core of why
we're stuck because I do feel like I
it doesn't matter what I decide we're
stuck because Brendan has lost respect
for me because I'm reading the same
material as him and I'm coming up with
different answers
and he thinks my answers mean that I am
brainwashed
um and so if I go all the way out
I can't I I'm lying to my children
because I don't
I don't believe that I don't believe
this church is false if I stay partially
in and allow Brendan Brandon to be
himself and
um teach his things as well as me and we
kind of go forward together with
different police but we show respect I
feel like I'm not going to get the same
respect that I can give him
what do you think about that
I I didn't what was there a question I'm
saying yeah what do you think about that
yeah no I I understand that
um yeah I think those those feelings and
and that's part of uh what we're
struggling with is just coming up with a
good answer for that and it sounds like
a lot of that comes on me okay so a very
common path
um and it's a it's kind of a buzzword
right now deconstruction my friend
Justin McRoberts is a um doing some
extraordinary coaching work with folks
who are quote unquote deconstructing
their faith whatever that looks like
he's awesome he's a great thinker along
those lines
um
and if you go back to scripture actually
and I don't want to be a preachy but I
think Jesus was the first one that that
talks about deconstruction you've heard
it was said this way but I tell you this
right so you thought it was this way I'm
telling you it looks like this right and
that's all throughout scripture
um
part of the deconstruction process is
becoming untethered and to what you know
to your routines to the cosmos and then
you have this season of Shame
what an idiot I was and then there's a
season of anger I got pissed off at my
parents at the church and then it's easy
to when we find feel ashamed and we feel
angry
one of the great soothing Band-Aids over
shame and anger is to blame somebody to
go after him
and we start going to war with our
heritage with the people who did Evil
things which every group on planet Earth
has evil people in their past we start
getting down that road and then after we
feel some superiority of blame
we feel intellectually Superior
I I feel this way because I'm smarter
than you and you're dumb
and that's where relationships get in a
mess
when somebody starts looking down at the
work the the word Christy said I feel
disrespected
um or I feel like he's losing you're
losing respect in her that's where I
want to spend most of your focus
here's the deal with your kids one of
the greatest gifts you can give your
kids is to acknowledge openly and
honestly here's the adventure that I'm
on
um I think uh four of the greatest words
in the English language for a parent to
a child is the words I changed my mind
I used to believe this and now I believe
this and in a year or two I may believe
something a little bit different and
here's where I'm headed and here's why
I'm headed that way so this the
obsession or the Panic about having the
right answer to give our kids or we're
going to screw them up make no mistake
you're going to give them baggage dude
what you want to do is to be able to
teach them model for them when you have
baggage regardless of how it got there
whether it's a coach or a teacher or a
girlfriend that dumps you or some mean
boy or somebody who abuses you or
whatever life will give you bricks in
your backpack you'll get baggage this is
what it looks like to be in relationship
with somebody and both of y'all figure
that out so in my house my wife and I
both identify as Christian we both go to
the same church we have radically
different beliefs on certain topics
certain issues
like she she my wife will roll her eyes
when I try to explain something and
um I'm not I don't I can't roll my eyes
that well but I'll be like I just think
you're missing the boat on this and so
we have this a similar value structure
but we have very different beliefs in
our house and my friends who identify in
the city who go to the same church and
we have very different beliefs we have
very different beliefs on how I've Got
Friends that cannot believe I work where
I work
I've got one friend and I love her to
death and she's like every time I listen
to your podcast I just want to yell at
you because you're so wrong on all these
things right so that's just like that to
me I don't there's not a disrespect
there it would be disrespectful if they
weren't honest with me
um so here's my concern Brandon that you
are taking a moral Superior High Ground
and that's a dangerous place to be do
you feel yourself going there and I only
say that because I've been there too
like I look at other people like you're
dumb for not believing X Y and Z right
uh yeah sure
is there a way to
model for your kids
um this is what changing beliefs look
like I was taught this as a kid as I've
gotten older
um I don't believe this anymore here are
some really great things that I took
from this though I do think a weekly
practice is good I do think Community is
good I do think singing is good is there
a way to find the good or is it just
scorched Earth for you
yeah I mean I think there is a way to to
find the good in it I mean because more
than anything it matters to Christy so I
you know want to support her in that and
and you know not have her disadvantage
something just because I I no longer
think that way I think like my struggle
is
I I just reflect back on my own life and
why I think the way I do and the
teachings that are taught and it's like
man I just feel there's a lot of harm
and so that it I I gotta I gotta find a
way to know that you know the parental
view is going to have more of a sway
than what teachers and leaders are
teaching them right but well in in
Christy this is where it's really
important he said an important word I
think this is harming our kids
and
belief in a higher power belief in love
belief in Salvation belief in value and
worth
um there's no harm there
belief certain things being communicated
um that harm your kids
that's where you Chris you have to sit
down and say I think our kids are being
hurt or you all got to find some sort of
common value there or some sort of
common language there
um
here's what I really want you to spend
your energy moving forward Less on
worrying about the kids
they are going to pick up the marital
tension they're gonna pick up Brandon
when y'all get ready for church the
huffing and puffing and the eye rolling
and the
they're gonna pick up way more on that
than they are
some Sunday school teacher telling them
some weird thing about some weird
whatever
they're gonna pick way more up Christy
sitting there in church by herself or
not going and her huffing and puffing
around the house they're gonna you see
what I'm saying they're gonna absorb
that tension much more than being open
about
here's where we're going here's why
we're doing this I used to believe this
I was taught this I don't really agree
with this I believe this and they're
going to tell you this today
um I don't I don't believe that I
believe this and at some point you all
have a conversation about here's where
we're gonna end up
um there is no smooth simple way forward
the only path you'll have forward is to
agree that we're gonna do this together
and that if anybody feels morally
Superior anybody feels I've got to call
a timeout that you feel empowered to do
that and it's real easy to suddenly not
be able to do that anymore
is that fair
yeah so when you say a timeout meeting
like
when some when I you know when the
respect isn't fully there we just call a
Timeout on the discussion and circle
back well it's you Christy being able to
say I feel like you think I'm stupid
right now
yeah or Brandon you're back on your high
horse again I know
I know that they're gonna say this and I
disagree
um and Brandon you giving her permission
right she gets to decide when she's
disrespected and and vice versa you get
to decide hey
this this is going to harm our kids I'm
telling you I've experienced harm from
these messages or this particular
message it scares me to put our kids
back in that and Christy you gotta hear
that
okay right and
merging cultures is hard changing Minds
is hard changing beliefs is hard
it works best when we can do this
together and what I don't want to see
you is you all lose your marriage over
this
are you both in yeah
oh yeah
yeah
Christy's like oh yeah Brandon's like I
mean
I'm messing with you dude I'm messing
with you
um Brandon let me ask you one more quick
question are you out completely of all
Faith are you done with it
no no it's no it's uh I mean there's
obviously like multi-levels of
deconstructing what's going on because
sure once you feel you've kind of been
LED astray it's like well now do I want
to explore my faith in Jesus my faith in
Christianity my faith in the Bible and
like I'm trying to like just pull the
brakes on that really hard because that
stuff does matter to me and it's been
forming for me and important and I want
my children to have that how are you
doing how are you how are you doing your
do you have people walking alongside you
in this are you watching a lot of
YouTube
that's that's a that's a great question
I'm definitely like the only person I
know who doesn't watch YouTube on a
regular basis good for you
um well thank you I guess
um a lot of it comes from like the
initial aspects of it there's like for
example this has obviously probably been
a pretty common issue with numerous
faiths is people questioning stuff and
whatever
um and so I tried to stay pretty basic
on far as far as sort of like initial
research on it uh like the church itself
has a link on their website of troubling
things about their past and so in this
whole process like I I know like in the
back of uh everyone's mind mine included
it's like is this always what I wanted
like have I always doubted but like I've
really liking this process tried really
hard to stay where I am because you know
trust me I'd rather be doing something
else than having this conversation like
a lot of men but
um as I go through and like look at
stuff like I was looking like through
sources through the church and then I'd
well I didn't know that I was never
taught that and then I'd like click on
all the source material which would link
through
you know deep uh how would I call it
there's like archives there's all kinds
of information of posts and sure I would
read like the whole thing and I just
finding more stuff and then just being
like am I in a Netflix documentary like
what is going on okay so
I'd read all these apologist books like
I read one book I tried it was hundreds
of pages and I got like 13 hours through
the audiobook and it just like kept
opening up more and more stuff it was
like it really felt like I was watching
like that Netflix documentary it's like
wait am I in this and so that's that's
really like how how this is kind of
formed and started and like yeah now
there's every now and then there's other
things I come across or things that pop
up that I I'm more open to reading where
in the past I was taught oh this
person's view I've like heard the name
and they're the devil or whatever right
okay here's your here's your here's your
here's your homework okay yeah
um
this weekend yesterday I flew to Texas
for a funeral did a day day trip and um
one of my family members passed away it
was a hard day and
the the small little chapel was packed
and I heard stories about my family that
I didn't know
and I saw family members I haven't seen
it a long time and I was like whoa
and I learned things and heard things
and saw things
and if I'd read that in a book
it would have been a very it would have
been very easy to de-personalize it
to see it in black and white
and hearing these stories in the context
of everybody getting together
in communion and community and love and
grief and sadness and we laughed like
crazy
and we shared a meal together it
provided a new context
so here's your here's your homework
um I want you to stop going down the the
information rabbit holes
that stuff's really important
but I want you to spend some time
talking with people who've walked away
from their faith
talking people in the Christian faith or
in the Mormon fact what I don't care who
talk to wise people
um and stop trying to absorb all of this
by yourself with data
um
and we have completely in my opinion
ruined Faith with info we've just gone
down a rabbit hole of data and info and
this and that and we've we've completely
lost the communal aspect to this the
wisdom nature of the of the conversation
across all different faiths so I want
you to put down the reading for a bit
put down the podcast for a bit put down
the documentaries for a bit and I want
you to spend a season talking to people
listening saying hey I'm about I think
I've lost everything
and I think I'm I'm I feel like I'm
hurting my wife I feel like I'm hurting
my kids I don't want to I want to love
them but I can't keep doing this anymore
and spend some season and wise counsel
and let's start there and Christy and
Brandon both of you the a thanks for
calling and being open I know this is
very very hard and by the way this is
the United States right now homes are
dividing over do we go to church I'm not
going to that church anymore this church
I don't believe in anymore I don't
believe in any of it anymore I'm at the
church of vegan whatever or the Church
of CrossFit or the Church of Starbucks
or whatever like we're seeing it just
shift in in our country and I want
people to Circle back to the core
relationship first
who are we who do we believe what do we
believe why do we believe it
what practices back up that belief how
do we live those practices out
throughout the week what are we going to
pass along to our kids
all of those things are critical and
important
but let's start with a central core
Mission we're going to keep our marriage
strong and I promise to
um honor you you promise to honor me I'm
gonna do the best I can to meet your
needs and I'm going to do the best I can
I want you to do the best you can to
meet my needs and I won't keep secrets
I'm gonna tell the truth and I'm not
going to think I'm better than yours
morally or intellectually Superior to
you
and also when I say hey this scares me
or this hurts I need you to listen to me
we're going to start there
and then we're going to surround
ourselves with wise counsel there are 5
10 15 20 years ahead of us on this
deconstruction Journey
let's go that route
let's go that route and my promise is
over time the conversation will shift
from a matter of Doctrine in a matter of
this and that to a matter of peace and
connectivity and all sudden the the
whole conversation about faith opens up
in a way that is so much bigger than any
of us could have ever imagined thank you
all for being brave and having this
conversation grateful for you